green scarves in front of Argentina's
Congress once again it's a long-running
demand from human rights groups to
legalize abortions in this South
American nation things need to change we
need a law that protect women we will
continue fighting until abortions are
legal in this country in Argentina
abortion is only allowed in case of rape
or if a woman's life is at risk and
women having illegal abortions could end
up in prison myself 3 Marty says the
fight for legal safe and free abortions
is a difficult one because opposing it
is the powerful Catholic Church things
need to change we need a law that
protect women we will continue fighting
until abortions are legal in this
country in 2018 the legalization of
abortion was discussed in Congress for
the first time it passed the lower
chamber but the Senate rejected the bill
every year thousands of women mostly
poor are hospitalized because of
complications with botched abortions
many of them died because they did not
make it to a hospital in time afraid
that they could face criminal charges
the new bill has not yet been sent to
Congress but reports suggest President
Alvaro Fernandez is likely to do so next
month there are conflicting reports on
what type of legislation will be sent in
whether I would seek to legalize
abortion or only decriminalized the
termination of pregnancies Cornelius
congresswomen Carmen PO Jo things there
is a big difference between the two in
the beginning President Fernandez spoke
about decriminalizing abortion and we
all agreed a woman should not be
persecuted for a seeking a painful
solution to her problems but now we are
seeing changes and he's talking about
legalizing it and it's a completely
different story I don't agree with
abortion being legalized it is not
something that will help our women
because it's a traumatizing experience
but women here do not agree they believe
Argentina needs to advance in women's
rights and legalizing abortion is one of
the ways to achieve it Teresa Waugh al
Jazeera bono Silas